où sommes-nous pas lindisfarne c'est
certain au balo là
mauroy et des vikings nous ont attaqués
et avons nous là votre fille
ils l'ont faite prisonnière si vous
parvenez à me ramener ma fille vous
recevrez une récompense généreuse nous
partons en chasseur
vous n'allez pas la moindre idée de quoi
mon père incapable qui es tu pas mal
pour un homme de foi
il est prévu que le feu consumant tossou
entrez dans la tour
et avec moi
il faut trouver un moyen de les ralentir
je m'en occupe
nous ne pouvons plus reculer nous
n'avons plus le choix
je refuse tout abandonner
aujourd'hui encore je refuse depuis va
mourir en vain je moureu dans la
bataille
viking montrez-vous sans pitié